how's going brush my name is Fedor bad
welcome back to some cry of fear I got a
lot of colors in last episode tell them
yes have to call my mom and this guy
keeps following me Jesus Christ let's
jump up on him let's try him haha I'm
riding him all right
not like I ride your mom all right let
me go take me to Mordor
what what it's not simply right of
zombie it's a modern diet all right so
now we're gonna call this men's
advertisement all right it's five four
three two one five all right stupid
sound mates I'm gonna call my mom
five two three two one no wait a second
wow this is a good calling Wow mama
taught you
mom are you breathing like that what the
hell is that maid mom you know what I
don't like this new attitude of your mom
ever since you hang out with those
citing these kids which number she's
mental divine Oh five two four seven
five two four seven help me what what's
the number again five six nine seven
five four - no
there we go God we're getting worried
that no all right let's enter the door
of darkness because why not okay I have
many reasons why but we have some good
news for us we have a baton you mess
with me you mess with baton and when I
was wanna [ __ ] with me can open these oh
this is like a storage or [ __ ] I don't
know why you would store [ __ ] it's not a
good idea my mom tell me when I was kid
pity stop starting [ __ ] keep telling you
you're so stupid
alright would help if my mouse would
work normally
alright problem solved yeah welcome game
ok what is this let's go down here and
take the other stairs that was where oh
he said follow the part for darkness I
know it was a clue how's that I don't
like this what's that oh no mom mama in
here oh no no here we go mom what Oh
senoritas senoritas everywhere it's ok
that's totally fine everything is fine I
don't like this hello
follow the path for darkness so natesan
show me the way sorry except
okay it's okay
half of darkness lovely absolutely love
oh look at this stairs always been a big
fat the weight I went down here silly
pants path of darkness oh no I forgot to
go out oh ha ha
that was a creator of dry fruit came
online all right he's gonna get a bunch
of friend if I snap oh is that Zen one
with a tango with me
I know Tango Foxtrot 2
maybe a little okay I lied I don't know
Foxtrot whatever don't judge me okay
let's go down here
what is this baton stupid alcohol never
does anything all right let's go down
here you all know my good studies I do
okay hello anyone down here hello I
don't like this brush hello yes
what a monster you splashing someone is
flashing over there stop splashing that
good
alright let's save here saving like a
mayor's mayor alright
I can also splash what what is this
what's this is the sound
oh [ __ ] you no love at all baton baton
baton you speak oh no you became fat all
this [ __ ] you should feel oh that's a
little fat on my tongue but hyung
all of you but hyung eat it no don't
become fat I hate when you become that I
don't know me gusta I can splash - you
know you hear this it's not really
splashing but okay camp mode stop stop
that [ __ ] Blackie splashy and hit you I
slap you I slap your left nipple a
slappy right nipple I kept all of them
nipples [ __ ] those [ __ ] freakin you
through kiss
Oh No Oh love you I slap you for
disrespecting man Bob did everywhere
that [ __ ] slap raping me Holli shut
them out of here see you later
nice to meet you lovely okay that's
enough Lee lovely wife you hand over
there alright slap you I'll slap you
I'll slap you I stop now
I don't want to do that again what I
have to for slap knees or is it nipple
guys to make a [ __ ] come back don't
they [ __ ] all of you oh what a little oh
you're not [ __ ] married ox no one
likes you anyway
holy [ __ ] alright run like a boss like
about like a man bang a beer beer you
betcha baton baton but tongue in your
face right nipple left nipple
Lady Gaga would be proud of me you know
that ah ah ah alright anyone else wanna
[ __ ] with me huh huh police Ben what are
you doing policeman policeman always
been who did you kill this time the
bridge policeman I don't trust this
water not one second not oh no segunda
policeman policeman what are you doing
policeman policeman my talk hey why do
you keep taping ah I don't even know
anymore
this is a pumpkin lovely yeah yeah it's
not touch that oh I have a bad feeling
about this
no me gusta lost fella sauce I have no
idea what I just said but I said it and
your stop
I hate there I'm sick of your [ __ ]
you're not a Murloc and you're not lady
gaga either you're [ __ ] bad
impersonator stop slapping me no one
likes a slapper no one not even lady oh
not that way not that oh stop it I'm
sick of your [ __ ]
sick of your tongue I'm not a girl you
cannot lick me holy [ __ ]
Oh what are you looking at thank you for
saying Italy I mean not watching I mean
what oh thank heavens
Oh snappy snow I gotta take a facebook
picture there we go all right huh that
was a good one hope there's a tape
recorder somewhere and I just climb up
here maybe we can find more police bill
I think police bill has something to do
with this I don't trust policemen but
this is Construction Yard no police be
less obviously something to do with this
what about dead power I can't trust
anyone no one noticed um don't nobody
know nada okay no it's not Charlotte hey
nice pipe lovely can I go in through it
oh I could
laughs ly lovely please tell me I can
use this oh no it would have been epic
yeah whatever so happy all right thanks
back Facebook Facebook I'm tagging you
mr. Lampe hey tag all right where do I
go this is a partial I hate Pasha are
you doing that I slap all of you maybe I
go through here and one no did nothing
Oh lovely
ah climb I died I died
I died in the situation see you in a
couple minutes all right
let's climb up and not [ __ ] up this time
like I don't even know that part is so
scary I don't like it I don't want to go
through it another time I wish I could
find a that would go climb like a normal
person down to the sewers to Lady Gaga
and nipple monsters I wish L and
generous were here right now she would
be so proud of me Ellen she would give
me a tap on the shoulder like she always
starts and be like pity I love you even
though I'm a lesbian oh that's it is
that's so typical all right Ellen
DeGeneres she's definitely on my zombie
apocolypse team for [ __ ] salon my
schnitzel daesil Fritzl all right baton
and gun you can't go wrong with that no
sure you can never go wrong with scout
for ammo we got nothing right lamp lamp
I'll see you on the other side lamp
lovely
Sam Lorna hey giving it a time then she
another yummy tikki I'm Hailie cute kid
yeah hey ba ba ba ba ba
Sawada still go there so pat down hello
that oh no my talk oh oh he speaks I can
two of them happy zoo all right I'm out
of here
yes I've claimed simply out of there
what the hell huh ah it's just time to
relax and tongue my tongue what's up
with this room there's nothing oh all
right that's not bad let's put away the
bit tongue and just kill him like men in
the attacker in the old days is there
something else in here a pen
okay all right let's do this pushpaka
what a leave me oh no I didn't [ __ ]
reload I thought I'd reloaded that's not
good all right
it is real Odin what the hell you look
[ __ ] you to come here I dare you I got
y'all you got dere together forever
hey Tom Mona Claire lady hey something
is blocking the door
it's gonna hear them a grudge lovely huh
odd kind of stuff but it says we need to
get that key all right what's the note
says Jeff welcome to today thank you but
now my name is not Jeff I'm sure your
supervisors already gone over the basics
but here's a few things you might not
know the cave is wet such as my vagina
call and filled with puddles such again
such as mine ah watch your step
Segarra breaks every two hours most
important if supervisor is dick remember
the code is section d you're going to go
back and forth all day so memorize it
the code is 2 1 2 7 9 the last number is
covered in ink I can't read it
alright that's a problem and we can't do
anything about that
what about this can we do anything here
maybe maybe I can set this on fire oh
but how no you can't shoot it all right
we need something a match or something
to blow up this door I guess and then we
can go to the other room like a bit
maybe all right I'm pretty shot actually
so let's find some matches all right
sure it's got to be safe somewhere maybe
in here oh we need the last code here
that's not good all right there we go
thank God I'm a genius for just testing
oh why are these dears but a cave I'm a
big fan of cages always liked him on
Facebook ever since I created my
facebook what are you doing you were
supposed to take me to Narnia but to
help taking your photo that's creepy
give me my baton I will teach you a
lesson
Patong Patong Patong Patong
I start to get for not taking me to the
lion alright
oh this is really creepy [ __ ] you Matan
stop crawling crawling crawling like
about you
brawling crawling crawling crawling god
I keep crawling what is this box of four
shells nine shells it's for a shotgun
I'm gonna get a shotgun Papa's got to
get a new shotgun Mama's gonna be so
proud like a I don't even know how proud
she's gonna be she's gonna look on me
and be like even more proud than Ellen
DeGeneres fire no oh no no no no no no
I'm back here I'm going back here you
just stay there being bloody and [ __ ]
some of you obviously had some period
issues all right I'm gonna ah
like favorite enjoy subscribe to come
abroad today and I'll see you next
episode this is what you get go away I
hate dad I'm sorry I love you I don't
Kat it's too late hey shut up shut up